when you're sleeping your brain is  repairing  it's healing itself so throughout the  day something called metabolic waste  builds up in your brain it's what she  calls brain cell poop right and when you  sleep your cerebral spinal fluid  channels open up and a kind of water  rinses through your brain and it clears  out all this [ __ ] that builds up during  the day  if you don't sleep properly if you don't  get eight hours sleep a night which  feels like a luxury to a lot of people  in the united states if you don't sleep  eight hours a night your brain does not  clean itself this is why people who  sleep less are far more likely to get  dementia you literally build up with  [ __ ] in your brain your attention will  be much worse you know that kind of  hungover feeling you have when you're  tired  it turns out that's because your brain  is literally clogged up